security has been stepped up across sri
lanka on the anniversary
of the largest single terror attack in
the country's history
on easter sunday in 2019 suicide bombers
targeted churches and hotels
killing more than 260 people the islamic
state group
claimed responsibility but despite an
investigation no one
has ever stood trial for the attacks
chilling surveillance footage shows a
suicide bomber with a backpack
striding into a packed church on easter
sunday 2019
moments before the deadly blast
the explosion here in san sebastian's
church
north of the capital colombo killed 115
people
[Applause]
i heard about the huge noise then i
jumped into the
church and i saw that my daughter
near simultaneous attacks also targeted
to other churches
and three luxury hotels most of the dead
were sri lankan catholics although a
number of foreigners were also killed
a commission set up to investigate the
attacks recommended prosecuting sri
lanka's then
president metropolis sirisena it said
political infighting surrounding the
president
had led to a lapse in security and a
failure to act on warnings
from foreign intelligence services
[Music]
but families of the victims say they're
not interested in a political blame game
last month catholics across sri lanka
came to church dressed in black
to express their sadness that two years
on those who organized the attacks
have yet to be identified
[Music]
the archbishop of colombo has said if
the authorities fail to come up with
answers by april 21st
the second anniversary of the bombings
he will call
for a nationwide campaign
more we're joined now from colombo by
security analyst asanga abaya gunasakira
welcome sir uh two years ago more than
260 people were killed you were actually
on the ground to witness that how has
that tragic
event changed the country
well i still remember that day i was
with my family
my two kids at the shangri-la hotel
bombs went off and so i was few minutes
behind
going into the breakfast area so i still
remember the pain
and the suffering of those people the
victims
the body that was carried right in front
of me of the
the woman was lifeless
um yes so the memories are still
without society and with me and my
family
so um i we share the pain and
yes i mean we look for some sort of
answer from the authorities of course
there have been two commissions which is
the parliamentary select committee as
well as the
presidential commission on this
again two years running and no one's
been arrested why do you think that is
well i'm uh with the cardinal on this
the
archbishop of malcolm ranjit who
has clearly mentioned that
the report the presidential commission
of inquiry decoy which is the latest
report
is incomplete when you study that report
basically it has i mean there are names
that have been
clearly mentioned such as the former
president the igp
the defense secretary on negligence
of their work um there was also
a clear
report on basically the report
highlights
several recommendations so why isn't it
getting implemented
uh why isn't um is the question that the
the general public has um
it's quite sad it's been two years and
there's not been
any sort of charges or any any anybody
being responsible
so these things have to be implemented
so
it's quite um i mean when you look at
the overall
democratic space of the uh the country
uh as well as the minority concerns
which has been highlighted by the u.n
human rights council so these are
serious concerns that the country is
facing be the muslim community with the
christian hobby
i mean almost all the time sure we only
have that concern
i'm sorry to interrupt you sir we only
have about half a minute but i want to
ask you i i'm i'm curious as to
what changes have happened in that
country i imagine
that it's uh it's it's only heightened
uh the fact
that the tension between religious
groups the fact that nobody's been uh
arrested yet and i wonder whether as a
security analyst whether you worry this
could very well embolden bad actors to
strike again
yeah i mean two days ago there was
arrest on extremists in the eastern
province
there was two or two arrests done so the
government is actually
um going on with the extremists you know
preventing
violent extremism but the militarization
footing is very strong in the country
uh as reported by the human rights
commission so there is a serious concern
between the balance between the civil
as well as the military uh nexus so
these are concerns but
while the the christian community wants
some sort of justice
uh say i mean for their victims as well
as
where it's sort of leading i mean out of
157
witnesses there was only one witness
according to the report was said there
is some
foreign uh involvement but it doesn't
say clearly
it mentions a name called abu hind but
it doesn't clearly mention
where it's sort of leading so this is
where the cardinals
are concerning okay uh security analyst
asanga abaya
sakera in sri lanka thank you so much
for your time
thank you
you